you wrote a book and it's the title that
I find absolutely arresting
which is life worth living
and the first question I have for you
is what is your favorite story that
captures the essence of what you're
trying to impart
it's the story of my family my father
was on the death march after second
world war my father met there
another fellow
inmates you might call them and and this
person was so possessed by a kind of
certain Equanimity and certain kind of
uh a joy that irritated my father to no
end that made him Curse God and
everything in the world even more
because there's this person who could
have a stance like this in the situation
of of dire need when their lives were
depending on hanging on on a thread so
what you mean by is they're doing this
Death March and he's saying what a
lovely day for a walk
almost that's how my father experienced
it in fact this person was trying to
tell him about how God is love right and
it just totally did not resonate they
were then in a labor camp and and a
river river Sava uh in Croatia was
separating two sides of the same camp
and they were separated and this person
swam across the river risking his life
in order to talk to my dad
about God being loved and what I think
was behind that was that this whole hell
in which we are right now is not the
last nor most significant thing we have
to say about the world
there is a foundational goodness even if
we cannot see it right now so as an Act
of Faith and after that act my father
who was completely enraged by
circumstances suddenly he was at one
point arrested in this
and transformed
almost in the moment I started to sing a
song about
God's love and transformed his daughter
life he was a different different human
being and I thought
what an incredible thing this
holy fool calling whatever it's
completely impractical man
who seemed to live outside of the
reality actually
was living connected with the reality
that was more fundamental
than anything that was surrounding them
and he communicated that when they
basically rescued my father suddenly his
whole world transformed nothing changed
but his world inside from inside toward
outside has been transformed
to me that's incredibly inspiring
my great-aunt uh survived the Holocaust
and she had her first child she gave
birth to her first child on the train to
the Concentration Camp she was actually
born on the train
and
her and her husband survived the the
camps and
she told me when I was quite Young
that you know you came out of the
Holocaust one of two ways
you were either stronger or you were
broken that's it you either came out
stronger you came out broken those are
your only options
and she said I came out stronger
my husband came out broken
and that's why we need each other
[Music]
you know and this is sort of reminds me
of
your father and the holy fool
that there's a there's a relationship
the idiot the enlightened whatever you
want to call them
I doubt he could have been
that person
without someone to sacrifice for like
your father
if he was alone I'm not sure he would
have been able to do it
that there had to be an element of
service
you know that if he was all by himself
he he Madness probably would have ensued
but he had purpose because of your
father which allowed him to stay in that
heightened State and your father would
not have become who he was without
somebody there
as well I think that's that's really
really beautiful
[Music]